it's incredible you become like this
champion of creativity
imagination intuition
and it really is like at a whole
different axis than a lot of our current
um schools are teaching at so
what is that movement looking like like
what is that energy so you've got like
um uh seligman and pen
you've got like but like what does it
look like writ large and
who are like the major figures in
addition to you
that are trying to push things in in a
more human direction so they have
big positive education conferences you
know with like thousand thousand people
from all over the world you know come to
these conferences
um but it you know if you if i can just
give some shout outs peggy kern over in
australia is
um leading the way of positive education
in australia um it for some reason
england and australia in addition to the
us are the ones that are most
um interested in positive education and
um
you know virtually all of australian
england educators come to these
conferences
so it's really big over there um but
there are certain schools like even in
philadelphia a shipley school is
is leading the way um in terms of uh the
entire school is based on a positive
education model
so there are schools um that have this
so um
yeah and there i could name schools in
australia that are that are doing this
it's very interesting to me scott that
you cite international sources because
i have this sense that's been building
over the last number of years
that american culture and thus a lot of
our schools
are really really um mechanical
uh hyper competitive in a particular way
like it kind of built to like kind of
try to
crush like a bunch of people through a
gate that can only accept
like like some you know like uh like
very small proportion of them and that
we're all kind of trained this way that
there's like a real
um sort of competitive savagery to like
a lot of like the american
system uh and that extends from uh our
educational institutions to our economy
which now our economy is like the most
savage winner take all thing that you
know in human history
um uh at this point um and so when you
talk about people who are working on
positive education like you're like oh
the aussies
like the uk and i'm just like you know
uh come on america like we
like america genuinely needs like a
massive
uh expansion of humanity i mean i it
that's so well put that i wanted you to
be president
again i'm just going to repeat that
again i'm just going to repeat that
again like
that would have been such a um uh
amazing uh
thank you i appreciate it yeah no but
the expansion of humanity is absolutely
what we need
but um if i may if i may just go even a
little bit further to more concrete
proposals because
i really do believe in bringing data i
believe in evidence i don't
um i don't want to make arguments you
know if you try to build
something on um on just ideology for
instance that's like building
something on uh you know a sand castle
you know like
you need it to have uh evidence based
just to a certain degree and you have to
be flexible to update the evidence in
light of new information
um so um i think that these following uh
basic human needs are things we need to
learn more in an education system and
they have a really strong
evidence-based and positive psychology
and humanistic psychology for them
so need for connection okay that's a big
one in our school system right now
um kids are uh profoundly lonely of
course right now being a virtual
that's even uh even worse and then so
you have a need for
uh safety and that can include you know
feeling as though your environment
is um that you've a secure attachment to
your environment you know attachment
theory comes into play here it's
important to have a secure attachment to
your not just your parents
but we don't often talk about the
necessity of having a secure attachment
to your teachers
you know like who's who's talking about
that you know
um and what that just means is that you
feel like you know they have your back
if you fail if you fall down
you know that you you can trust there's
trust in your environment we have a real
trust crisis right now in america with
each other the next one in my revised
hierarchy of needs is the need for
self-esteem um but i specifically talk
about healthy self-esteem versus
narcissism
we do see a lot of uh narcissism around
you know in the current generation would
i say that the current generation of
kids get mad at me
a lot of it's social media man i mean
there's like a real you know i mean you
literally have numbers attached to how
many people
like you exactly
exactly but that's different so
narcissism is you know how
um you think you're you're better than
others but just a healthy self-esteem is
that you just think you're worthy
and i do think we have a um a crisis of
people feeling as though they're a lot
of people do not genuinely feel like
they are
are worthy and you know and you made the
argument in the scientific american
article that this is tied to
um the way we're treating people through
things like uh the economy or or the
lack of universal basic income
it was one of the points in my campaign
was like look if you had universal basic
income and then you could all look at
your
child and say uh your country loves you
your country values you and and you're
going to be all right and we're going to
invest in you
like you know and and as someone who's
run organizations i've made this
argument
it's like you can always tell if an
organization is investing in you and if
it's not
it takes you approximately two days to
figure out if an organization
sometimes yeah it's like right by the
second day you're like okay
like i see what's going on here and and
this is one reason why when
organizations put on these
frankly kind like sometimes uh sort of
like overdone or
ridiculous like trainings or boot camps
or in like
rituals and whatnot um no matter how
like frankly like dumb it is um
it actually still shows like a form of
investment like they're trying they're
willing to like
spend company time unlike
you know like whatever the the training
rig moral is
that's actually an excellent sign in in
the scheme of things
um even though some of those things are
you know a little uh ham handed
um so right now our country
in my opinion um is not investing in
people
in a genuine way and people are kind of
picking up on it and then
i mean it's like like do you feel like
you are worth something
you know you can put on a brave face but
then like when you press on it like a
lot of people
you know are struggling with it i i
couldn't agree more
i couldn't agree more um and we're not
uh we're not listening to each other's
uh suffering you know we're we're kind
of putting our own suffering in a lot of
ways as
uh and a lot of ways we're not realizing
that a lot of other people are
really going through uh a lot of this
same kind of suffering even if it takes
a different form yeah basic
need the basic need is unfulfilled and i
think you know it'd be wonderful if we
could rally around
the common humanity of the uh basic
needs that are being unfulfilled
versus um making everything into a
coalitional thing where
you know our suffering is is so
different you would never understand
you know um i i mean i just want to move
towards a world where we we try to
understand
at least well these are universal needs
you've identified that would be very
hard for anyone to argue against it's
like look like shouldn't each of us
have you know like a feeling of
connectedness and safety and esteem
and so so the values you're identifying
right now
are something of a recasting of maslow's
hierarchy of needs
in your latest book uh which i believe
is called transcend is that right
uh this book came out um fairly recently
i want to say just last year
oh look look what i know well for those
of you who have the video that there's a
copy of like
the book what's this doing here what's
this doing here go ahead and read us the
subtitles scott
uh yeah it's the new science of
self-actualization the new science of
self-actualization so let's continue
past uh the the need for esteem
excellent
so first of all maslow never drew a
pyramid so that's a big misconception i
talk about in the book that uh
p everyone's you know everyone knows the
pure the pyramid with like wi-fi at the
bottom
or toilet paper at the bottom yeah it's
it's it's a meme
um it turns out mazzo never drew a
pyramid so i have a sailboat metaphor
so i argue that we have a boat that
needs to not have too many holes in
there so you don't go anywhere
but if you if you just have all your
holes you know if
you if you just have the boat secure
you're still not going to go anywhere
unless you open up
the sails and and and and risk going
knowing that the winds could come
crashing down any time knowing that
um uh i don't know if that was right
metaphor wins i don't know if winds
crashed down but anyway you see what i'm
saying
um waves crashing down waves crashing
down winds
you still need to go in your mind which
is the bottom of the boat is that
uh safety is that connectedness and
safety so the boat is
security and and the sale is
growth and the three needs that comprise
security are these are safety connection
and self-esteem so the ones we just
discussed was the boat like we already
did
all of the three of them are like the
hull of the boat i got it that's the
boat that's the boat okay
and if you can have those three needs
secure you feel like
you can start to explore the world in a
way that you feel vulnerable
yes i love it and this is one of the
arguments i was making which was like
look
like you can't get people concerned
about climate change if they can't put
food on their table that day you know
what i mean
like and so so you have to address like
the
um connectedness safety and the steam so
what does the
mast look like like so if you open the
sail yes
if you open the sail so whereas the base
of security is safety
the base of the sail is exploration
the need for exploration is a really
deeply evolved need we share with other
animals but it takes unique
manifestations in humans because we can
bring in the intellect
we can bring in intellectual curiosity
that was another finding that i that i
that i um found in my dissertation
research was that intellectual curiosity
was not the same thing as iq
um i found it was only about a point
five zero correlation oh there
are some very uh bright people that are
totally in curious
not curious at all yes yes
not one iota not one iota um so
um being able to do what we call in our
research we call it cognitive
exploration
so you can have behavioral exploration
like you know like columbus set sail and
you know that's the physical
adventure seeking but you can also have
cognitive exploration like the human
imagination
you know like man alive is just like are
you reading books and stuff you know
what i mean but you talk about
the need to explore yeah exactly um so
that's the base and
and if you can go so when you open the
sail you are uh
moving with uh the spirit of exploration
you're not driven you're not driven by
fear anymore
see this is the distinction that maslow
made between deficiency motivation
versus uh growth motivation wow
when you have a deficiency motivation
everything in your life what you're
trying to do
is to make the world comport to your own
uh wow do we have a lot of deficiency
motivation
exactly we're living in a deficiency
motivated nation that's correct
yeah that's what you know the language i
used on the campaign was mindset of
scarcity but
it's it's the same thing same thing
exactly exactly
um so you know because when you're
hungry right you're saying feed me
when you're when you're profoundly uh
lonely you say
you know like me um when you don't feel
like you've respect then you start
saying respect me i deserve respect
but but all that takes the flavor of the
deficiency realm of human existence when
you can get to the if you can
uh get to the being realm of human
existence or the growth realm and open
up that sale
you are no longer driven um by
what you are deficient in you um uh
you're very forward-looking and you
you're driven by
a spirit of exploration of the unknown
and you're okay with the unknown but
most importantly you have what maslow
called be
love love for the being of others it's
it you could think of it maybe like
universal love but i've tried to make
the case in my book that
the need for connection is different
than be love
you can be very very connected to people
that um
share similar political beliefs or
religious beliefs or in your in
group and have a lot of hate for anyone
that you perceive to be in your out
group but when you have
being love you really have a deep
abiding
um love for the being of everyone that
you meet there's kind of a sacredness to
the the uniqueness
so is is that the sale is that the fifth
thing after do you need to explore
yes yep that's exactly that's exactly
right so uh exploration and then
be love and then the third one is the
need for purpose
so i argue it's a whole system okay so
if you're driven
by a spirit of exploration you have a
humanitarian kind of
loving sort of uh orientation so it's
like look i you know i'm
i love people that uh may disagree with
me or like i don't have certain things
in common with
exactly and you have a sense of purpose
um so it from this sailing metaphor you
have a very clear vision
of what island where you're going where
you're going even though
you might be very far away from your
going and even though you know there's
gonna be a lot of setbacks there's gonna
be like the
the sea is unknown you know like that's
life folks
i'm sorry to like tell you that santa
claus doesn't exist you know in a sense
say
like you know life there's gonna be a
lot of unknowns
and uh and but you still have to go you
still have to move
so so one side of the ledger is
deficiency motivation the other one is
growth motivation is that right
growth or maslow called it um the being
realm of human existence sometimes
he uses those two the b realm the b
realm
so i think most people listening to this
can easily understand and relate to the
need for connectedness
connectedness safety and esteem uh you
know if those
those things aren't present then it's
very very difficult to
feel like you know you you can um make
positive things happen or even that you
know you deserve
things like you you do deserve a
thousand bucks a month i mean that you
know
uh and then the the higher order
uh needs are around um
the ability to explore um to love
people that aren't like you necessarily
and then have a purpose um and
uh you know if you ask many people i
think you know like what is your purpose
they'll look at you like you know like
like it's a very very odd question
frankly
um and i think there are a lot of people
that think like even trying to ascertain
your purpose is like a very privileged
pursuit because
at that point it must be that your other
needs are being met um
and this is all tied together where
there are so many americans who are
struggling right now in ways big and
small that
you know it's like like trying to have
someone trying to address some of these
higher questions
a lot of them aren't in position to be
able to um
consider them very rightfully so you
know and it's one reason why
as a society we have to do a much better
job of
trying to address people's sense of
safety and connectedness and esteem
you